yeah welcome to New blitz game let's go
for something else b3 should i play with
a form yam booth with black having
committed to e6 the sir make some sense
yeah in this in this very classic game
Laska against Bauer they played Alaska
play Bishop d3 not in this exact
position but a very very similar
position yeah of course he doesn't he
doesn't play a pleasant lady five okay
still what is this my phone is sniping
um how do you continue now maybe queen
to g3 to have this display on the long
diagonal and then maybe you can can
improve the position tween h4 queen age
forms also not not ridiculous he may be
intense night c5 this is a bit bit
annoying don't want this bishop to to be
expelled
hmm ya know c4 to get c2
peugeot Queen to h4 at least now I can
play 94 this is the problem okay let
them create a square on c2 for this
piece it's all a bit a bit strange of
course it was played very much to hit
two to stay along the lines of this
classical laska game I can play Nancy
for a 95 now and then 94 but maybe this
isn't so terrible okay it doesn't go for
it maybe just if I offices plan I don't
know I need to retreat this anyway
yeah I thought tweenage three would be a
good reply putting him into this
diagonal so i have this pressure on age
seven maybe 95 yeah so a surreal threat
now needs to be cautious maybe you
should consider g6 now g6 in fact I can
take on you for I'm play 95 hmm now this
is strong he cannot go g6 aha
interesting age 6 hmm
yeah let's try to get rid of the slide
it's it's strong piece
yeah and now I thought 92 would be a
nice idea to sort of say okay you've got
two nights for one square and I expel it
with d3 maybe
wow this looks dangerous I think
k
what about what about 95 now is this
just an irritating move or is this a
strong and don't have much time can
probably just take it
let's just let just improve the position
it's uh I shouldn't try for some cheap
tricks yeah Nigel interesting but I am I
just have from a good control of the
center I don't need to do anything crazy
I can just advance my Center supported
by the bishops and have a good position
so we'll take this on yeah why should I
take I wonder I come on I only have
little time g55 it is it is certainly
dangerous for for both sides but I
control them I really control the center
of it it should be should be okay well
okay i need to be good him
check
the IDS Bishop see one now kicking the
Queen back and of course I'm i have the
threats taking on g6 e6 and so on
Queenie 323 didn't see that at all I
hope it doesn't lose instantly okay I
don't understand it frankly
yeah he's got the bishop move the ship
deform
just trying to prevent this yeah what
this is just winning now if seven
explodes yeah it was it was very messy
this position I really not sure Bishop
Defoe of course water lemon now by black
but maybe he had something i don't i
don't know it's um it's complicated
yeah just win the rook basically with
was amazing it take on top doesn't have
he doesn't have anything
yeah it's okay okay okay yeah I don't
want to look for the under promotion
this is even made check me nice nice at
the end funny funny you made um yeah I
don't know probably he had something
this g4 was computer gives us as winning
for white yeah it's probably not a
surprise but I felt this was still very
messy here just wants to take 26 cm I
wasn't sure I wasn't sure I did always a
win according to the come to the to the
engine hey this is a casa immediately
over yeah then it was probably okay g4
was very young what's a bit loose but it
is strong probably a five this is just
just the big threat I've got all pieces
on the king so should be something yeah
thanks for watching